this week's episode is brought to you in
part by Q eco Cuba co-creates super cool
hands-on projects for kids of all ages
that make learning about science
technology engineering art and math fun
inspired creative confidence this year
with Q eco Cuba Co is offering science
magazine podcast listeners the chance to
try them for free to redeem this offer
and learn more visit kiwi co.com slash
magazine that's ki WI co.com slash
magazine this week's episode is also
brought to you by the Pew Charitable
Trusts podcast after the fact it's been
more than thirty years since a new type
of antibiotic has made it to market now
I bet you're wondering why a stat is
only the beginning of the story to
understand the numbers shaping society's
biggest challenges listen to after the
fact a podcast from the Pew Charitable
Trusts available on stitcher and
anywhere else you get your podcasts
visit Pew trusts org slash science mag
to learn more
welcome to the science podcast for
January 18th 2018 I'm Sarah Crespi in
this week's show I talked with staff
writer Paul Busan about comparing the
insides of the two biggest planets in
the solar system this is based on data
from Cassini at Saturn and Juno at
Jupiter and Megan Cantwell talks with
science writer Laura Spinney
about fighting in Ebola epidemic in the
face of conspiracy theories and fake
news in the Democratic Republic of Congo
first up we have staff writer Paul Busan
he's gonna talk about dueling a
spacecraft Juneau at Jupiter and Cassini
at Saturn and what they can tell us
about the interiors of these gas giants
hi Paul hello so the first time I
brought this Cassini paper up to you you
said you've been waiting for a year and
to write about this what what was the
holdup or how come you timed it that way
so the Cassini mission ended year and a
half ago I believe it was September
where it burned up in the atmosphere of
Saturn and it had always been promised
that these gravity results would be one
of the hallmarks of this final campaign
and part my job is to chase down these
types of results that you know meetings
and things like that before they
actually reach the pages of a place like
science
they were very canny and not presenting
it so I've been hunting for this and
waiting I knew the Jupiter results came
out but I wanted to compare and contrast
with Saturn so that's why I waited till
now okay so these are gravity results
what exactly were they measuring about
Saturn's gravity when the spacecraft is
it's orbiting the planet and as it comes
really close to the atmosphere tiny
variations in the gravity inside the
planet can actually cause it to speed up
and slow down that results in a small
shift a Doppler shift in the radio
signal that it sends back to earth oh so
the craft itself is speeding up and
slowing down just a tiny bit in response
to the gravity and then we can read that
in what radio waves are being back to
earth yes this actually we send the
radio waves to it they're reflected back
okay we measure the Doppler shift in
that very cool so what are these tiny
shifts indicate in the gravity of Saturn
one big question was the winds on Saturn
also on Jupiter but scientists have
always wondered how deep they reach are
they shallow like the earth or do they
reach all the way deep down into the
planet those are the two camps
so when you say shallow you mean that
they're there taking up a big percentage
of the atmosphere like yeah essentially
they're just like the wind on earth so
you know this is maybe a 1% of yeah nice
fear okay or there's something much
deeper which is definitely possible
because these are giant planets and
they're very gassy very far down right
yes so what what are the gravity
measurements from the Cassini mission
say about the winds on Saturn so they
actually found that the winds went down
about 9,000 kilometers maybe 10,000 and
which is in between these two ideas of
what they would be and that actually was
corroborating findings also on Jupiter
so the two have kind of matched up to
form this new theory for why when
stretched this certain amount of depth
and then the planet locks up and rotates
like a solid the winds they're going to
a medium depth in both of these gas
giants what do you mean
locked up like a south as you get to a
certain depth the pressure it's just
crazy down there and you get to about a
hundred thousand times the pressure on
earth and and at the pressure and heat
the hydrogen kind of partially ionizes
so it becomes like a semi conductor okay
you know too much deeper and becomes
metallic but this is not that region
okay so the semi conductor hydrogen can
be influenced by the magnetic field of
the planet which then arrests the
impulses of the wind from higher up
reaching down as the magnetic field does
not like to get crossed up further down
further down there is probably a solid
core is that supported by Saturn Cassini
readings and Jupiter's you know readings
so the cores are really I still a big
mystery so on Saturn especially they're
really just trying to still puzzle out
what they know about the core so there
are some suggestions we have to use
these models to kind of interpret the
planet so everything is kind of
contingent on this model but there are
some suggestions that perhaps the core
is more starkly defined on
then on Jupiter where it seems to be an
indication that on Jupiter it's kind of
this very diffused thing we don't know
on either if they're solid or liquid or
whatever I mean really we don't know if
they exist or how you define a core
right so if there's no borders and it's
not a solid is it just the center part
of the planet it's like a heavier
concentration of what they call heavy
elements it's essentially everything
that's not hydrogen and helium right can
you describe some of the kind of the
extreme features that make it so
difficult to study the interiors of
these planets these conditions these
would not be habitable conditions on
Saturn the the winds there especially go
I think about 1,800 kilometers per hour
at the surface near the equator the
planet spins incredibly quickly you know
it gets full rotations about ten and a
half hours though that's uncertain by
about fifteen minutes or so still not
resolved like the Earth's like a ten
hour day it's like something how many
times bigger than the earth spinning
that fast yes amazing a lot times these
fuzzy borders on Jupiter's core it kind
of makes this question how these planets
were formed if they don't have a rocky
core did they ever how did they start if
that wasn't the way it began right so
there used to be this kind of Cusco
theory about how the giant planets
formed gas giants formed that you would
have this core and then it would suck up
all the gas from the protoplanetary disk
but this could be an indication that
perhaps as Jupiter was forming the rock
or ice was vaporized up these high
pressures and the gas is being entrained
at the same time so is all this kind of
melange from the start rather than you
know this kind of stately progression
hmm let's go just some specifically
Saturn things and that means Saturn's
rings but also something you call the
dark side of Saturn's gravity why I
don't I don't know what that is can you
tell me this is a coining of Luciano's
lead author on the paper and essentially
they're able to explain you know certain
parts of the gravity signal they got at
Cassini but then there's also this pole
that did not match up with when
something from the deep and
of Saturn they just couldn't explain and
they know this signal is not present on
Jupiter because we have the parallel
Juno results and really no one knows
what it means it could be something
manifesting from the wind that they
don't understand perhaps but it could
also be something about the interior
that they just love the depart a lumpy
part that has it could be you know lack
of convection or no really just no one
knows there's a very strange
gravitational signal in there somewhere
yeah there's not a model for it yet no
okay very cool that is the dark side of
Saturn's gravity so one other thing I
learned from this from this story is
that Saturn vibrates in a way that
affects its rings can you talk about how
that relationship works and what that
means that rings can tell us about the
interior Saturn yeah so for some reason
we don't know Saturn vibrates it could
be something about these you know winds
distorting it or it could be all its
tiny moons pulling on it but these
oscillations manifest themselves in the
Rings and these little patterns inside
the Rings that scientists have known
about since the nineties that form kind
of from the broad scale of the spiral
arm kind of like a galaxy's spiral arm
from these you can actually conduct they
call ring seismology and infer things
about the interior of the planet so you
can look at that pattern and the Rings
and know something about the gravity and
the shape of what's going on inside of
Saturn yeah it's I mean it's a tricky
field it's really only it's barely been
pursued a few really pioneering
researchers have pushed it through
people been painstakingly looking at the
Rings over the Cassini mission to you
know find all of these features this is
you know a couple dozen features people
have found so it's not a ton and they're
still starting to piece together what's
happening there very cool so you know
there's a real potential there that you
might be able to tease something out
about the deep interior of the planet
that you couldn't get with the other cuz
you need data one other thing that we
wanted to get to from the Cassini data
is the age of the Rings how is that
determined and and how old are they this
has been a big question this was one of
the primary things they hope to figure
out with Cassini especially in
finale so they're the longview that the
rings were kind of massive and old you
know maybe as old as Saturn or closest
oldest Saturn and what they've done with
this the grand finale is since they went
between the Rings and Saturn they were
able to measure the mass of the Rings
the mass of the Rings was much lower
than some scientists have thought and a
low mass means a young age based on this
understanding of the mass of the Rings
Wow old researchers think they are so
they actually think they're between 10
and 100 million years old they could be
younger than the dinosaurs the
extinction oh really so if they have
been looking out at Saturn they would
not have seen rings if there were
dinosaurs strana Murs yes that is very
good
okay Paul so what's next for looking at
the interior of these giants no there's
gonna be a lot of data to still plumb
Juno is only halfway through its mission
so they'll have a ton more data there
there is no mission plan to Saturn in
the future right now people have been
calling for you know dedicated orbiter
but that you know there's a lot of
planetary science to happen and Cassini
was a big mission so this might be the
best data we have and that might be a
call for more of this ring seismology to
get out what's going on and to see any
data will be keeping people busy on its
own for decades right thanks a lot Paul
yeah it's my pleasure
Paul Busan is a staff writer of science
you can find links to the research and
his new story as science magic spot
guests stay tuned for Megan Cantwell's
interview with Laura Spinney on
countering conspiracy theories about
Ebola in the DRC
[Music]
this week's episode is brought to you in
part by Kiwi Co Q eco creates supercool
hands-on projects for kids that make
learning about steam fun with a Cuba Co
subscription each month the kid in your
life be it your own child your niece
your nephew your neighbor will receive a
fun engaging new project which will help
develop their creativity and confidence
imagine getting an all in one project
you open it on a Saturday morning you
don't have to go to the store and buy
felt or seeds or soil anything it's all
in there and there's also easy-to-follow
instructions and an educational magazine
to learn more about the crates themed
everything is created by cue eCos team
of in-house product designers and
rigorously tested by kids which i think
means that it's not very breakable cuba
co actually has seven different types of
crates to choose from so anything from
the tadpole crate for infants the Koala
crate for preschoolers I have one of
those all the way up to the Eureka crate
for anyone over 14 I guess that means
adults to queue eCos mission is to
empower kids not just to make a project
but to make a difference Kiriko is
offering a science magazine podcast
listeners the chance to try this for
free to redeem the offer and learn more
visit kiwi co.com slash magazine
[Music]
there's an Ebola outbreak in the
Democratic Republic of Congo with 609
confirmed cases and 340 deaths reported
but public health officials are faced
with problems beyond just treating
individuals who have contracted the
disease I'm Megan Cantwell and I'm here
with Laura Spinney to talk about how the
effectiveness of the response to a bully
in the DRC has depended on combating
misinformation surrounding the disease
hey Laura try is it likely that a bola
will spread to other regions in the
Democratic Republic of Congo
they basically seem to be able to
contain into one place and then it pops
up in another and then they contain it
again there so it's not spreading very
fast but they haven't quite contained it
yet
North kevvu which is where the epidemic
is is on the border with Uganda so it
there is a possibility that it could
spread across borders
if the w-h-o declares an international
emergency that tends to trigger
countries neighboring countries to close
their borders and there's fairly good
research that that actually doesn't
necessarily help in containing an
epidemic that's interesting why is it
that closing the border wouldn't
necessarily help because essentially you
push the problem underground one of the
most important things in controlling
Ebba is about tracing contacts they're
tracing people who have been exposed to
patients and if you close borders stop
people going about their normal economic
activity for example then you reduce the
likelihood that they're going to be
visible to people who track those
contacts they're not just fighting a
bola
in the DRC they're also fighting
misinformation which you talk about in
your piece and one of the most striking
quotes that I found was from someone
from UNICEF Carlos never Oh Colorado who
said that he usually tells his team that
they're fighting two outbreaks Ebola and
fear could you explain what he means by
this it's a very frightening disease and
fear is a problem wherever it crops up
it was certainly a problem in West
Africa in 2014 2015 in the much bigger
epidemic they had their DRC has an extra
set of problems in that especially North
Kivu the regime we're talking about
there's a lot of fighting still
there's basically smoldering conflict
there there's a lot of political
uncertainty you may have been following
the stories over the presidential
legislative elections in DRC there's
been outbreaks of fighting which have
periodically shut down the the whole
response mechanism to the epidemic do
you tend to see a little spike in cases
after that happens each time but
basically the whole atmosphere is right
for mistrust misinformation and fake
news of all kinds which doesn't help in
fighting a dangerous disease people are
afraid to come forward even if they have
other diseases for example malaria and
so people are dying of treatable
diseases as well
that's why Carlos Navarro Colorado
talked about two epidemics one of Ebla
and fear which is that the fear keeps
people away from clinics altogether what
are some of the misinformation campaigns
being spread about Ebola it's important
to say I think that North Kivu is an
opposition stronghold it's very much
opposed to Joseph Kabila who is the
outgoing president so a lot of the
rumors had to do with Ebola being a
creation made made in government labs
government creation in order to wipe out
opposition voters and voices for example
one of an opposition and politician who
actually said that on the radio and a
local radio station and there are all
kinds of rumors also connected to the
experimental vaccine the Merck vaccine
one of the rumors about the vaccine for
example is that it renders its
recipients sterile absolutely no
evidence of that there's another problem
which is that because the supplies are
relatively short they've been putting in
place a ring vaccination system where
they don't braixen eight everybody but
they they vaccinate around the
population affected in order to try and
limit the spread that has been in itself
a source of some suspicion because the
people of DRC are used to mass
vaccination campaigns where everybody
gets the vaccine but if only certain
members of the population get it they
start to wonder why is there reason that
person's getting it and not me so that
all sorts of rumors flying around and
the campaign is working very hard to
suppress them and to get accurate
information out there so what kind of
strategies has the Public Health
response been to fight this
misinformation so they have a lot of
social scientists and what they call
community engagement workers out there
and those people are constantly out in
the communities gathering information
about how people are perceiving the
epidemic how people are perceiving the
response and they are feeding that
information back into various kinds of
online dashboards that have been set up
by the aid agencies involved to give you
an example one of the most contentious
issues has been about the so-called safe
and dignified burials which is the
protocol for disposing of the bodies of
a beloved tombs in a safe way so that
nobody is contaminated there was a rumor
that the bodies were going into opaque
body bags but in fact they weren't they
were being stolen and their organs
harvested for sale I think that this was
related to the fact that people were not
able to perform their traditional
burials as they were used to being able
to do and so there were all sorts of
suspicions and resentment around that
there was sort of two prongs to the way
the responders dealt with that one was
informational they put out accurate
information about why the burials had to
be done this way explaining in
educational videos for example and the
other was on the sort of more
procurement side this epidemic is the
first time they got hold of transparent
body bags so that family members could
actually see their deceased relatives
going into those body bags and then into
the coffin which would then be buried
and therefore their you know to kill the
rumors in fact that they were not being
buried these initiatives have been
pretty successful then you know they
have the impression that they are
winning the information war there are
various signs of that to give you one
example just after Christmas on the 26th
of December the National Electoral
Commission announced that Bennion Burton
bow which the two cities which have been
foci of the outbreak would not be
allowed to take part in the elections
because of the epidemic that triggered
two days of protests because their
opposition areas and they felt they were
being silenced by not being able to vote
and during those protests and Ebola
evaluation Center was attacked but what
was interesting was that after that
happened a lot of the opposition
organizations in the area put out
messages the same that they can
the decision of the Electoral Commission
but they wanted the ever response to be
protected so you could see that they was
making this separation now between the
politics and the Ebola response and the
responders national and international
agency is trying to contain this
epidemic considered that a small but
finally significant victory have they
seen more people come forward who
suspect that they might have a bowler
displaying symptoms yeah so one of the
really interesting indicators is that at
the beginning people who suspected they
had symptoms were basically going
anywhere but the official ever their
treatment centers for a medical opinion
that was taking them a lot of stops if
you like along the way by various
different kinds of traditional healers
and local clinics before they would turn
up at a treatment center now basically
that chain is much shorter people are
much more likely to accept a referral to
the Ebola treatment center which
suggests that you know the kind of fear
and opacity around those treatment
centers has basically been reduced by
the information campaign and a lot of
things have contributed to that that one
is organized visits to the treatment
centers by people in the community
starting with the leaders one is the
support of religious leaders in the area
the Catholic Church is very strong there
and a lot of religious leaders have been
supporting the campaign by for example
putting out information about the
disease and how its treated from the
pulpit on South Sunday morning some of
the feedback from the community
suggested that mothers were very worried
if they were sick about what would
happen to their kids when they were in
the treatment center so the responders
set up crash nearby those centers to
look after their children all of these
things have helped one of the messages
that came back from the West African
epidemic was that people found the
sirens on the ambulances that took
people to the treatment centers
stigmatizing so now the ambulance has
come to pick up people to take them to
those treatment centers are silent
they have no sirens so all of these are
examples of harrell the responses used
the feedback from the communities and
fed it back into their response to make
it more tailored to the local community
and to their worries into their
perceptions and to gain their trust and
cooperation yeah it's amazing how
coordinated and effort this is between
so many different groups do you think
that this model can be used to inform
future Public Health efforts
absolutely and I think you know there
are two elements to it so the first of
all is the gathering of the information
and the turning around of it very fast
feeding it back into the response that's
one thing the other novelty about this
outbreak with respect to West Africa for
example is that in the past all the aid
agencies who have contributed to the
response have been coordinated highly
coordinated but they've essentially done
their own thing and they've brought
their own expertise to the problem now
there's a very much more integrated
structure it's essentially one response
team which is headed by the Congolese
Ministry of Health and which revolves
around a single sort of incident room
you know liking in crime dramas is an
incident room which all the agencies
contribute to and I think that that has
also been very important because
information flows very much better
through the agencies themselves through
the responders themselves so I think
those two things have contributed to
this but we're nowhere by no means out
of the woods of course I thank you so
much Laura it's a pleasure
Laura Spinney is a freelance science
journalist based out of Paris you can
find a link to her piece at science
magic slash podcasts and that concludes
this edition of the science podcast if
you have any comments or suggestions for
the show write to us at science podcast
at AAAS 0 RG you can subscribe to the
show anywhere you get your podcast or
you can listen to us on the science
website
that's science magpie casts place an ad
on the science podcast contact mid-roll
comm the show was produced by Sarah
crusty and Megan Cantwell and edited by
Potter G Jeffrey Cooke composed the
music on behalf of science magazine and
as publisher Triple A us thanks for
joining us